okay hello and welcome to our Monday
even in a live show for an hour of blitz
in the five-minute pool or the auto
pairing as some people call it yeah
welcome to all of you in the chat
already recognized a couple of familiar
names I hope I'll be able to do this
show properly because I some are called
the akhada saw throw it a little bit not
quite sure what it is I don't have a
cold I assume but yeah I hope my voice
will make it through this hour ok so I'm
going for a five minute game of course
haven't played blitz for ya a couple of
days so i hope i'll do a right i'm
currently doing roughly it's ten
thousand four hundred as you see plan
plan fo risom i don't think i've played
this guy before so let's see what we get
one of those English lines with a five
maybe yeah this is a very solid line i
have to admit something that black
definitely is quite okay with I've got
good control of 85 though this is nice
so before here doesn't really promise
all that much so I'm going to prepare it
yeah yet a caprikat you could take and
then play em Bishop leave form so i
could go before here not sure if it is
really doing all that much Pusha page 3
10
it's probably not the greatest opening
ever yeah i'm currently playing my c4
repertoire I think it yields me good
positions I definitely get better
positions whether then with the with d
for 193 currently ok so here yeah this
was something that I have thought about
and maybe you can just go d 5 at the end
of all this I wasn't sure currently yes
this is possible I wasn't really sure
what to make of this if this is ok for
black probably it is I can take it will
be three maybe it's not not particularly
great I wonder if root b6 somehow an
idea you can take and play with the aid
ok so that doesn't do all that much so
let's go eat for maybe for Bishop e3 and
queen bee three frankee line predicts
English and bankers we will see yeah
this is currently what I'm playing also
my latest to project that I've worked on
ok so this is interesting here he wants
to go rock the eighth but ok I can go
look d 1 on that and I have Bishop g5 so
like here b5 Bishop g5 years to go back
and I wonder I can go for d 4 in this
position hi George he had already
checked out my bank rep Benko repertoire
I hope you liked the first look so we
will probably move this rock away I'm
not sure what to do after that yellow
two till oh no Kings gambit action catch
inconstancy I can mix it up a little bit
I will play one or two like normal games
and then do some other openings our for
ism is taking a lot of time it said
really big deal here i was thinking rook
c8 looks very natural him so i will do
here try to win that porn but ok
Brooksie five I go Bishop to e3 if I go
Bishop e3 here I can still do that rook
the eight I can take a couple of times
this is probably equal
going back meat grinder asked me what
compelled me to do the English
repertoire or the bank or avatar it's a
little bit different the English opening
repertoire I was asked to do it because
there was the feeling that there's
demand simply the people are interested
about on I interested in the opening the
banker was my idea because I played it
quite successfully recently and I felt
that I felt that it's also very
interesting for me to investigate I mean
the English also was a cool thing to
look at because it's something that I
have played a lot some years ago and
basically gave it up because of a couple
of lines I didn't like that much and
those I know were still interesting to
me so I was some pretty cool there's no
good book for black how to play against
bishop a 49 in the huge game with Queens
gambit declined I don't know of a good
book every eighth all things I know are
not very recent the latest book about
the black side of this is from John Cox
and this is from wow that's old yeah
it's from twenty ten or twenty eleven or
something like that so here I still have
a very very slight pool there is slight
pool it cannot take and I kind of
threatened to take and play rookie six
so he can go g5 but this is not a move
your love to play yeah okay here i can
take and
the rook possibly should 2d6 that
doesn't help okay let's activate
hmm ok I go on the seventh if i take can
take on g6 and make him take with the
king it's also interesting or with the
ruger time warning check okay meant it's
an interesting ones okay so it's still
probably going to be a draw draw a third
I think I'll take it ha ha ha that's no
way to win this position ok so I pressed
but it somehow didn't materialize but it
was a good opponents are not a big deal
I'm going to go for a new game soonish
yeah that was very sad news today that
mark turetsky passed away it's um I mean
I have no inside information or anything
and I was surprised i mean when i did it
start I saw that video series on that
non chest 24 with him and I mean I I
didn't really look like he might had
some I mean you never know yeah but he
didn't look frail or something sometimes
you see people on TV oh so he's a war we
still he's not looking good like him
there could be some illness go ahead it
didn't really look like that so um yeah
very sad news standard that he died
okay not sure about this here it's a
little bit of an offbeat Sicilian seems
he wants to go e five here right I
wonder if this is an idea I can still go
85 yeah well maybe it's not such a such
a huge deal him I don't know not a fan
not sure if I want to go five ok I'll
castle yeah i was thinking if he five is
an option this is this ephi from white
somehow worries me so I am stopping this
and I kind of the usual form of Sicilian
that I have played in the past is this
kind of society and Wham you have the
the d5 her wolf and let's see what
happens here I've got before and in to
go okay so he would put the knight on d5
him
you
so the thing is what am I doing here I
can try this and let him take on before
not sure him the ideal scenario here
would be darks bishops traded and the
night to see 5 i'm thinking of moving
the Queen and played a bishop da to be 6
that could be could be something aha so
a Bishop to b5 s what he wants to do I
can capture maybe and play the rook to
be formed nighty for by the way I'm just
seeing this I let's take him okay so
Quincy seven and then 90 45 hmm I also
still like to move the bishop over to be
six that would be something cool to to
manage it will see we will see what
happens there is ticket and I really
wonder what nope no explanation
whatsoever
complicated stuff there was actually no
question in the in the chat but I feel
like it's going to be topping up soonish
if I what do I think of mark Tourette's
keys books and do I have a special
recommendation I think I'm yeah so he
spotted this this thingy with the pawn
so I can take here actually why not i
can do that I wanted to take with a
queen but the a5 porn are saying but
this is not so bad i put a bishop on d6
and i have f5 coming up f5 and you form
an goose also didn't know what the cause
i can sinfulness or what that's pretty
awful if you don't know that yeah okay
my favorite turetsky book and i have a
couple of his books and it's difficult
to say to be honest and I think
ultimately we will go for the end game
manual or the entry only visited in in
German I think simply because it's an
extremely comprehensive book on the end
game and basically um everything you
need to know in a way about the ending
of course you can get more books yes
study whatever but if you get the
endgame a manual and absolutely work
through it which to be honest I never
did and it shows in my games I have
distinct trouble in the ending
especially with little time um yeah if
you go through the end game manual you
really have made a huge step forward in
your in your chairs knowledge and its
really basically almost the only endgame
book that you would ever need I mean and
then I'm very sure if you take the
anchorman you work through it really
really thoroughly you would have nkm
knowledge that is enough for the
grandmaster title but by far I mean by
far and this is fantastic such a
comprehensiveness and very good
selection of example so it's a I think
highly recommended are usually for the
endgame I am recommend the two books the
book by hazel stevia the 110 games you
must know it's very often recommended by
chest teachers and the end game menu if
you really want to dig deeper and really
like have it all yeah so this is what I
have to say I'm i think the end game
manual is the is the book to get by
durrett ski if it just like one book but
there are a couple of others I mean he's
written really a huge amount of books
there couple of others that are very
useful there is a serious in in German
actually i'm not sure if there's a an
English version version of it and like
three books f1 here this is prophylactic
thinking and this is excellent because
it basically highlights on one big
virtue of Tourette's keys material he
had fantastic really a fan fantastic
selection of examples so I'm warning if
you look at this for prophylactic
thinking you will get prob probably the
best examples for this subject
I look through the engine manual but not
in a knot in a in a way that is enough
to really learn it completely basically
lack of time and also um yeah i'm i'm
interested in the end game it's not like
they are not interested but it's not my
favorite part of chess study it's just
what it is okay so how do i do this here
each voice of course weakness but it's
not so easy to get to it I don't want to
trade that's what I know a poll is
definitely dangerous very nicely okay it
doesn't move it directly so I can stop
it for the moment that's good 46 was
kind of dangerous check yeah cause I can
sip for this is a from German comedian
yo yo and it some white foreheads on
time one of the few examples of good
German humor okay that's a question
about my banker repertoire and no i
don't i play something else there George
cannot really started go through to now
here okay playing any more chill yeah
right and I can go for a four-year why
not people requested the Kings gambit
I'm not able to do that now let's play
this that's funky he plays my line and
that's what I play with Blackie against
this pretty goo sixth now the normal
continuation a little bit surprised that
you're thinking about it but maybe he
forgot it
hmm
ok I think I'll go here so that the
night cannot go to see 5 I'm threatening
now aged 3 i'm not sure that there are
good gambits against the caro-kann i
actually doubt it
especially if you say good gambits ok
low let's see I'm threatening you six
here yeah so he prevented this from
happening I don't know Bishop d3 I can
also take him and wonder how he will be
captioned with the night menu let's
develop
yeah George I think you can play what
you suggest to play with e six and
Bishop before I mean black really has a
huge choice down my main reason for
choosing the line that I did in that
Bank report one was that it is more
University applicable for example this
position with knight c6 and Knight f6 am
then I'm suggesting this is some this is
playable in any kind of c4 c5 situation
so if you intend to play this kind of
stuff also from a c4 move order you will
always be able to play it that Bishop b4
line that you're suggesting is only
playable under certain circumstances so
I wanted to ensure that because of
maximum applicability let's say you can
play it basically what I'm taking this
pawn to give me a center pawn I'm taking
it and so you can basically play it
whatever yeah and this is what i always
think is important to play stuff that is
some usable yeah it's as usable let's
say as possible I wonder if my queen
could get into some kind of trouble here
to be honest
so he wants to play some e 5 stuff I
think I wonder if this is a good idea my
queen could get into trouble like 'if
I've takes takes 90 3 i'm attacking if I
of a couple of times but he might have
some idea am in that particular George
on that particular move order like d4 d5
sorry d4 Knight f6 c4 c5 93 takes and I
takes there's also a six-night c3d 5
which is also ok for black yeah but as I
said I wanted to do something I wanted
to recommend something that is yeah more
universally applicable it's not
essential for this this particular
repertoire on the on the on the bank
where you can play many things there but
it's good if you want to use this stuff
also for other purposes like fighting
against see form ok this one maybe I'm
kind of unsure him I try for Bishop f4
and if it goes f5 I'll take it and
tweenage form
you
Jim if I get Bishop f4 n then blacks
hope for having any compensation will
die down I mean his his pieces are
rotten anyway night on a 6 and so on the
only question is can you do something
about my queen which is very much
possible because the Queen has no
squares I mean I just think there is no
way to exploit it but I might have a
wrong judgment there ok but should I for
now I think it's kind of kind of obvious
I hope it works at least yeah I can just
go I can take right and now we have move
the Queen to e3 does no that's not 95
actually as this hangs with check I can
attack it can take a two maybe okay it
doesn't really doesn't really hurt all
that much I think the ad the book by
Health's turn on on end game strategy is
pretty good yes it's a very very decent
book rook to e7 looks good
yeah so Jack I can take here can take
this mmm but how is what's the best way
of finishing this off check looks like
there should be some kind of made which
currently I don't see it yeah maybe 95
currently only has one single check i
believe between a one king c2 is end of
end of game okay so he tries to use
Bishop f5 p.m. I can go to the to the
awesome if I check check and do this
Queen a one king you to s actually
playable and I'm threatening Queen B 8
made and made on b7 had all kinds of
stuff so maybe we can interpose on d 7
yeah this one that's true actually
and if I take this no time warning I can
still check me into play Bishop f5 hmm
slightly annoying check
it's just covered now be too I've got
covered black for fits on time okay so I
won this caro-kann game this is by the
way a pretty decent line against the car
also okay game very much time unless
summated line okay playing Alex with
black so this is actually a game that
was kind of announced to me yesterday
because this is a actually teammate of
mine and he asked me how actually can i
play you in one of your life session
that okay you have to have to challenge
and hope for the game to materialize so
we got this now you can take with the
Queen yay which is kind of interesting
probably should have I've made the same
mistake recently but okay we get a
non-conventional position here at least
which is not bad let's see if he takes
it nope it looks more like Sicilian
which is a good thing against people who
play like an idea 3c3 stuff play
something a little bit more
non-symmetrical but why its position
feels quite solid
can almost pre-move 96 now here I don't
pre move here I will probably play 94
again I just to be a pain right o.o
Queen a forward had quinsy six that was
close that was close I've almost
blundered the night so and what should
do here what's the correct set up I
would like to he's a roughly 2,200 over
the board to 150 to 170 something about
something like that it's a bit
provocative
but what I'm saying is I have the bishop
pair well it's a cool move actually I'm
saying I have the bishop pair what do
you have g5 trying to play this okay I
egos g4 here going for going for a
full-scale active play interesting and
probably not too bad how okay how much
my game against good died yesterday hmm
yeah play down Oh game over the watch as
yesterday it was a draw against a player
from Belgium I guess from swag god damn
it was an interesting game I wanted to
play the Banco but it didn't work he
declined this very very very quickly
with Knight f3 III some conservative
setup however we didn't get a boring
position or anything it was very
interesting we got to we got to some
model benoni structure where was a tempo
up but it was very complicated and I
have not yet analyzed the game I think
at some point I was having it looked
like a small plus but I couldn't really
do much with it so maybe my impression
was wrong or I cannot tell really I felt
like I should have had a good position
but it wasn't really yeah not much was
happening
okay so here this cannot be all that bad
for me but how to do this let's tickle
that be to pawn a little bit it's a
little bit or awkward see if it covers
this cell I Queen d2 I've got 25
attacking the bishop enter and 21 so he
just needs like one or two moves to
consolidate his situation but not sure
if he's getting that
George are so hot do you think it is for
someone over 30 to 35 to improve in
chess that depends on many factors it's
definitely still possible it's however
not as easy as in younger year so young
yeah the whole um how do you call it the
cognitive abilities they just go down
over time and and this yeah this is an
issue but on the other hand you can also
I think in some way benefit from from
being older and you've got more
experience and this helps sometimes to
do to actually be more efficient in
learning it also depends what you're
playing an evidence I think if you have
a pretty a pretty high playing level to
begin with and you have done serious
study and never improve before it's
maybe that you've gotten to some kind of
peek it's it's possible definitely
possible so how do you approach this
position here maybe a little Bishop 25
I'm not quite sure about it it at least
looks kind of active
I don't know it looks quite nice yes but
is it really doing all that much okay
here i can take take f2 right or is
there something bad happening to me I
don't see it at the moment check gonna
activate the King king forward okay so
many not this is one thing I made right
as correct often if your order you want
to improve your chess but you simply
have too many other things on your plate
this is definitely something that
applies to most people if you have a
family or if you have your job whatever
things that are arguably more important
than chance it will cost time and this
makes it often more difficult if you are
below them to improve it's not so much
about I came like I'm like your audience
to pedor anything like that it's just
that it's um it's a matter of focus in
some way time morning yeah that's not so
great i have to give a man a seven pawn
but i'm still fairly active and he's got
a little time on the clock that's a good
move that's a good move
hmm covering this is kind of lame maybe
after he would go Quinn j7 huh yay I
didn't play that all too well a5 I
didn't really pay much attention to draw
our third that's a that's a clever draw
clever draw from yeah I have to take it
now very clever draw off for now gab
espalda probably winning position him
but ok it was a good good game by Alex
ok so let's see I'm going to go for a
new challenge him so let's see I think
it's definitely possible to improve if
you old I think but it's a matter of
really can you do it is it a feasible
kind of idea yeah i mean i'm pretty sure
for example that that I could still
improve but started I don't see it
happening i have so many other things
just related that i do that i don't see
me studying chess all that much i have a
specific idea here let's see if i can
get that in ok i returned to the d4 idea
playing open Sicilian ok you can go with
you five something like that is
definitely possible
I don't have any water around that's
badly organized so we've gone we've
transposed to the souls in variation of
the Sicilian very sharp line I think I
had something like that on the board
last week and had a losing position when
did I start play chess that was my first
opponent and is that the game from last
week it looks a lot like the game from
last week was that against the same
opponent kind of curious how to say
actually and I learnt the woods when I
was pretty young maybe when I was seven
or something like that but I never
really played I only I mean I was taught
the rules but I didn't really play games
like it played with my father maybe 11
game and my grandpas something but I I
got more interested in when I was
roughly 13 14 years old and at the time
I played a lot it gets my my grandpa
which was very funny as sorry I told
before that he am here Pletcher he
played shares and he loved to play chess
board and there was one one particular
issue he um yeah well he had a wrong
piece set up you know he had knights and
bishops set up in the wrong order so the
bishops were on g1 and be one of the
nights on c1 + f1 and this is how we
played yeah for for a very long time and
then
there was this strange moment when I
actually bought a chess book and saw
that this was not quite right yam the
pieces have to be set up differently and
I told him you know is it this is wrong
word me what we did all the time so we
should probably switch it and ok then we
set the pieces of differently and played
like normal chess and yeah it's at some
point it was I was getting in wins and
so on it was I was getting a little bit
stronger just by playing but then I
started to like buy buy more books and
then end to enter a chess club and I
enjoyed the chest up when I was like 14
and I picked up things pretty quickly
yeah basically I played chess 960 before
me your chest yeah so I'm a pawn down
here I want to play some f 5 stuff he's
not moving um maybe it's not quite sure
what he should do here oh maybe
certainly this is an issue but I think
black is perfectly fine you can probably
play Bishop t6 or something like that I
wonder is there something is she or
something no I carry this one hmm
certainly making sense I mean I have to
have to do something drastic quite
quickly otherwise I'm just getting
killed probably and there is stuff here
with g 6 and so on maybe g6 and Bishop
takes g6 this is maybe crazy ok maybe
it's interesting h takes Bishop takes
and this kind of stuff it could be quite
interesting takes and I takes is good
for me and I'm threatening 96 if he
takes d4 Bishop takes I think I
at least for blitz game i have
compensation they also takes Knight eggs
wins for wide so he can maybe cancel it
maybe he can just castle here but ok
then I've at least got the g file open
uh-huh yeah i thought this should be
kind of okay right if you take see I
take is 6 that looks dangerous at least
and I'll threatening 26 anyway so it
cannot take air for I think you should
take the vision probably and yeah let's
and say like show me if I take on g7 by
the way when you see moving is rook this
is not so easy to answer he would
probably casts a long shadow think I
just do that get all the pieces into the
game and see what he's doing it's not so
easy for black e'er to coordinate it's
not quite clear what I'm threatening to
be honest maybe not all that much okay
if you move so look yeah okay he has to
go back what now Bishop b5 he has to
move the Queen hmm
hmm maybe the night to d4 yeah something
like that okay maybe I can take the five
I think just grab another pawn it's not
that I want the pawn in that badly just
that it also activates stuff yeah here
we should be five as a move 95 rookie
eight wins wins stuff it's overloaded
black resign yeah these kind of
positions they're always very tough to
defend them even even though it's
probably if completely incorrect but you
just are under an attack and let's tough
to say not even sure that this is losing
for black takes rooty 1807 maybe it is
okay new game so I'm pretty okay what
did i do we have this fashion did I
actually lose no I played two drawers
and had three wins so good stuff have a
new request I would a couple of good by
the way how did the the town memorial
fair so also speaker kramnik was a draw
at the end yes we had a very good
position at one point started against
chronic okay going for the gamey against
the blitz king
the Blitz King f5 I don't like it so
much play the carpool system not sure
that age three okay that's the idea okay
that's idea i see going for quick deform
ok so is going for very active player
interesting i try to put some pressure
on the center ok d 5 yeah he can go see
five you know and my bishop looks pretty
damn awkward but you sometimes get it
into the game quite quickly so i'm
trying to play for that c6 but should be
a 80 ok so if i play Bishop dat will
play b6 em ok um and if i take just take
twice is that is that so convincing come
on show me what you got
is it all that great maybe it is I
thought I can put the bishop 166 and I'm
not that badly off okay even f5 is some
option but okay I want you and 95 maybe
I can still not play the bishop he adds
a little bit a little bit annoying I
wonder I wonder if g5 visible it's a bit
crazy but ok maybe on 96
yeah this is an interesting position
really can I somehow put my bishop into
the game that that fricking bishop on a
seven I don't quite see it
he just wants to double
Wow let's indeed an idea totally did not
see that he can double okay so he
threatens to take them I can do this
though then I can also play Knight takes
e5 here potentially so and f6 is also a
problem
oh my god
this is probably probably a lost
position I didn't think about this move
yeah Knight f6 is unfortunately quite
deadly maybe but he can take you five
now here you can just take you five and
I'm basically chose Knight f6 I cannot
cover Knight f6 King edge 898 does not a
3 which at least looks tricky but
probably this is also not doing all that
much wow that I screwed up I think that
that should highborn he shouldn't have
been bad for black would be quite
surprised if it would have been at the
beginning of at least Knight f6 shoot
probably some e6 or something like that
is good for Queen Shack
mm-hmm as many things winning here yes
even this lazy moon probably wins
bloody hell okay that was stupid stupid
black resins absolutely sure that leg is
good here just want to briefly check
this okay I'm in trouble I'm in trouble
here because of the doubling I just
didn't see her okay to coming I cannot
believe that he can just play b5 here
and give me that pawn it's it's hard to
start to see I think be 60 ever seems to
be okay there maybe I don't want to
analyze all that much rather than to
foster the new game so that's grandma's
Demetria co venko who is it I have
spoiled a couple of very good positions
against him is a 2700 GM 0 out of 4
which is pretty stupid because I had
enough for at least two points let's see
I'm going for the for the English ends
see how I fair maybe you can play in
this yes I was just thinking that this
could be an idea have stupid stuff
against such a good player you cannot
afford opening missteps like that
usually not
all right what a bloody mess they are so
very nicely plata he doesn't even take
so okay just waits with this chick all
right doesn't check he just takes them
maybe night to be 6 s coming okay but I
cannot care about this at the moment I
have to get my get my king out of all of
all this so is that all that bad it's
equal material wise and maybe maybe my
rook is stranded okay this is an idea of
course just going for the light squares
very technical solution yes very much
possible book t3 looks like the most
passive move ever okay so this is not
play the more I guess how to play if it
takes I could go to the seventh which is
okay takes us 92 c 1 so he always has
this nice night going to eat to stuff
yes I said root these three looks like
oops terrible but maybe I can actually
do it for the moment oh it goes f5 or
something no he goes back
yeah okay I'm losing that pawn but
losing that pawn I just hope the aid huh
it's tough to activate he wants to go
see for I guess on 95 again but ok but
should be too is that feasible check
yeah I played that quite a number of
games against Nakamura over the years
usually just getting killed like
everybody does never played a camera on
this stream I think the strongest
players I played on the stream was
kawana that was a couple of month ago
and it was a pretty good fight I mean it
was a I lost this game but it was kind
of interesting it's not that he just
killed me instantly
Jim who let's lost yeah so good game
Riza certainly by yeah Kumiko that
opening was too bad actually III i think
is a mistake here until quickly rip did
she get em maybe I should start with a
three year I'm not entirely sure of
course I can do many things here d 34 or
whatever but what I did is probably
wrong this 95 is a little bit awkward I
think that I had this in a game recently
okay I playing one more game and that's
closing the stream
and we've got a very high rated player
on currently DFL he's got to 8 25 in
five minute which is basically out of
this world that is currently playing
bullets on
I have played many scars on the SSC when
he was 10 or 11 but that game is lost
maybe it may be here icc administrators
i can dig it dig it out grandmaster
champ Buster I've got the Blitz King the
champ buster yeah why not why is nobody
calling themselves lousy miserable [ __ ]
or something and they are all the champ
busters okay I mean I've also just
explaining on chess misunderstood so
it's probably the same thing sham buster
this kind of thing yeah hmm check and
maybe this is not so greater Magnus
username was just Magnus at the time
yeah I just I just play like nothing
happened to him simply ignoring that I'm
upon down how to say
I have to say that with my username
chance explained that this was actually
never intended um that I should have
that name in there and in the ICC or
even for the videos Jan the name was
born on when I had to choose a name for
my for my youtube channel and I just
came up with Chaz explain because this
is what a friend asked me to explain how
you play chess and I said okay then it's
just explained and at the time I wasn't
even called she's explained on the ICC
and had a different username and yeah
then it got kind of clear that this
interest in those games people watch it
and so I I just thought okay the name
should be Chaz explained so that people
kind of recognize when I'm playing that
I'm recording and so on so it's not that
it wasn't a planned action that seemed
to have this name it was happening
through the channel name because it
actually sounds a little bit like okay
I'm going to explain you how this game
is working blah blah blah it sounds a
little bit condescending or something
like that and it's it wasn't really
intended
so he goes all the way to a 5 to attack
this miserable porn I kind of understand
but still I still think that this Bishop
is pretty decent check okay so easiest
is probably f1 should be three he's got
rooked you won though hmm I can also
just take it I mean okay I'm a day after
a five let's not collect we're back a
little not quite clear where I'm going
yeah gambit has a book series conscious
explained which is a little bit unlucky
actually they had two serious before i
took this name for the channel and it
wasn't really i didn't have that on the
radar at all if i would have I probably
would have chosen something different
it's a little bit weird to have books
with this with this name or something
like that so what's going on here I
think I just take and to march the pawns
currently the night is not all that
brilliant what does he get in like c4
won't be fine I don't quite oh that's a
good move I forgot about that move
totally huh that's a bit stupid okay
I wonder if this is just to draw more if
you can do something probably cannot do
much
the only thing and this is the only
thing I can think of like c5 and night a
1 C 2 this is the only way to ever move
the mind so if i go Bishop deform go
there it's going king d 3 okay but if i
go see 5 in this position alright see
it's that may be a little bit much
ok this is a pretty crazy idea of it and
I'm no no I don't know maybe I'm just
losing now
on the other hand maybe I'm winning
couldn't quite figure it out night III
refi office could be the problem here
and that probably was too risky I wanted
to try to win this game and maybe that
was just not called for yeah the problem
is i can easily stop the porn but he
will get to the sex and then he enters
he enters my position and if he wins one
of the points is probably winning this
so this one night is sex maybe I'm still
okay
maybe I'm still okay it was just not
simply not a good decision because um he
is probably risking not much probably
timewise maybe but maybe I'm covering
all the stuff white resign he designs
why why if he is he's bringing his night
back isn't that a fortress I mean I
thought isn't that some kind of fortress
yeah I don't know maybe it isn't time
wise it would have been very tricky so
somehow I got a winner of this game
which was pretty and unexpected okay so
a win for the final game of the session
I hope you enjoyed it yeah yeah don't
ask me I wouldn't have resigned but
maybe it is actually a problem I mean it
looks like a fortress ER because of them
Bishop it might still be lost them and
yeah probably due to the time T Thomas
right thanks again for watching this
I'll be back next week next Monday same
time there will also be a new
simultaneous display show in october
probably are at the end of the month
rather than at the beginning ok guys
thanks for watching i'll be back next
week bye bye